good
[Music]
good morning how are my favorite menus
we're good we're tired I think I speak
on behalf of all Millennials when I say
the four day we're Creek has never been
so pertinent to the situation it's never
been so pertinent and like it's like we
only have like a three-day workweek so
we need to relax this has been the
longest week above yesterday just like
out of the blue I was attacked by Mother
Nature got my period and like honestly
it feels like an eight-day workweek
do you feel attacked I feel attacked I
feel really just kind of like
disappointed and like letdown you do not
know it was coming
no I've been do I get this thing where I
go through a lot of stress like when
during the wedding like I literally get
my period for like three months and like
it was very normal the doctor said and I
been going to like a lot of stress
lately obviously and I didn't even
realize I had like gotten it in a while
um but now I'm back because the dress is
about are you feeling chef anymore no I
think I'm like I still like pits that
night and like I think cuz you're
picking up things and sometimes I cry
myself to sleep you know because you're
human because I am a human being woman
and that's why you have an emotional
support dog it's true
that's how you're doing the best that
you have been so emotionally supportive
he's bit like he knows he's kind of a
wild animal at times but when you need
his emotional support like he can sense
that because he's an emotional support
animal and that's why he's registered
with the city right so without further
ado so Cinco de Mayo is tomorrow and
unfortunately we won't be able to
celebrate with y'all
what are celebrating cuatro de Mayo
today what am i lowering the toasts not
a good every time I see a cup like this
I think of Sex in the City which which
version women when they go to Mexico oh
and they always how many margaritas and
honestly like you guys are always like
why do you guys drink the champagne it's
because it's been sitting out here and
that gets warm and this is like 90%
margarita mix and it's just it's purely
decorative
also because like we need to deliver a
premium show for you guys if we're gonna
drink alcohol it'll be at the end or at
butter the show if we learned anything
from the CMA red carpet it's that we are
best when we're on whiskey and we're
best with our shoes I'm gonna be insane
no that was the greatest night of our
life it was a great a thinner my life I
was so tired no it was the greatest
professional layup yeah because like fun
wise it was fun because professionally
we were because we were breaking it down
having fun we were
selling internationally but you know
I've had more fun in my life yeah it was
just like that feeling that you get I
guess when you do really good works just
like what it means to be in Nashville
it's like people in Nashville just have
like times like that all the time how
nice and their rent is so low so they're
just like a living life and they've so
much budget and they yeah exactly they
have extra money for drinks begin
Nashville I'm just really looking
forward to a day like when all of this
toasters are like on the same periods I
go it's not cool
I think we should all shop all that
happen once you hang out with them like
you think that's not how it works
if you hang out if you like hang out
with someone so much doing one meetup
you're not all gonna get on the same
periods well I'm gonna work on it that
lets everyone like move their birth
control so we could all be on at the
same time and not all of us remember to
get all 100,000 of our listeners on the
same period side girl unless their boy
well even still you science has to take
this area you get Jackie and I have a
robust kind of world Cosmopolitan show
for you today her youth from business to
tech to celebrity news to these
celebrities in Russia to nexium we've
got it all do are we talking about
nexium today I can't talk about it
anymore I agree it's too depressing and
I was telling you I listen to the juicy
scoop podcast because she had like a
nexium expert an expert on the show and
I learned nothing so I'm out do you ever
put your hands like on the no because
I'm always like Catholic I just feel
like a happier woman doing this I'm
gonna stop no it's like kingly I have a
special announcement do you - sure
I love making special announcements as a
influencer slash blogger I feel like
it's my job to make big announcements
and like builds up a lot of hype to them
and you have must be working on special
projects secret projects well you know I
have a couple secret projects you know
in the in the docket but this one
specifically I just wanted to let
everyone know that because all the GA
tickets sold out for my Caroline show I
actually got some more tickets released
to GA so the cheap tickets are available
I don't know how many for each show but
it's a limited amount so if you go to
the Caroline's website all four shows GA
tickets are now available they're $25
you're welcome wow that's really good no
no maybe Co can afford it now I don't
know he said like on a major budget
because he just meant a camp and that
was like super expensive for him and he
left his credit card at camp so it's
like this whole drama with the oh oh
he's so irresponsible with
his money what's up oh also just want
another housekeeping announcement and we
rise to the patreon account so many of
you have signed up and are loving the
episode and requested that we do a
patreon Facebook group oh yeah which we
have it's called the toasts after dark
you can only get in if you are a patreon
member and Joe thank you Jackie's not
double-crossing it because she's
checking her lucky she's making a list
and a second to take me down so I am so
if you want in that group just join the
patreon and then in that group you can
talk about the episode and also have a
direct line to us to ask for whatever
you want in the next episode we'll
probably do it because we work for you
totally and I just want to say like our
first episode is just getting rave
reviews and I really think it would
behoove me to cry in every episode and
like I'm not like a we know because of
the patreon episode it's like there's a
difference between hearing someone cry
and like seeing and they feel like
hearing it on the podcast like is your
change
trembling of my voice and it's like if
they see it maybe they'll be like oh
she's gonna die yes they can't call you
crocodile tears on a podcast I meant
about know it really did get such rave
reviews and I remember after he recorded
it like I really felt so bare did you
yeah like I feel like we really just
when we gave it all up we really did and
I look forward to doing that more I
think it's really therapeutic and I'm
glad that you guys get to see us like
you've never seen us before which is
what we promise and you know I think
their goal people are just ask me like
what is your goal for your brand brand
and I never know what you say but I
think I just figured it out okay Claudia
what is your goal for your brand I don't
know I had a joke and it was based off
of something he said no I don't remember
what did you say I said that'd be and
showing you a slightly nervous oh yeah
okay so okay
ask me again Claudia what is your goal
for your brand I just want my brand to
be seen like it's never been seen before
on multiple occasions like I want to
keep reinventing myself and keep showing
the bread people what the brand could be
like you've never seen it before
I think it's an amazing goal I think it
is so far so good you're on track holdin
your time you are hitting your quarterly
benchmarks I totally agree
the group is called the toast after dark
and this only four page remember is so
subscribing our patriotic 70ad
patreon.com slash morning toast couldn't
be simpler okay let's get into the past
I story so you need to know free wake up
and take a bite out of your mummy
because without further ado you just you
can't go on for one more minute today
without knowing these stories mm-hmm
no one will want to talk to you even
though you probably know them already
you don't know what we have to say about
it therefore you really not happen yes
so it's like don't you want to
contribute you know cocktail party
conversation totally first up Gigi Hadid
responds to black face accusations so in
case you didn't see Gigi Hadid was on
the cover of Vogue Italia no fee fie foe
feed was oh of course it was not only TV
caffeine it was offensive yeah yeah
because she's looking very dark and
she's speaking up about her
controversial new Vogue Italia cover
shoot the images shot by famed fashion
photographer Steven Klein featured the
model looking heavily tanned and nearly
unrecognizable which quickly sparked on
accusations of blackface on Thursday
afternoon Hadid tweeted a paparazzi
photo taken on the same day as her cover
that shows her complexion looking much
lighter suggesting that the images that
ran in the magazine had been digitally
darkened or she like took the makeup off
yet oh shoot is there like a locker room
after a shoot yeah it's like you have a
whole studio to let the shower to do
studios have showers they should
well like the fancy vote ones for sure
just like milk studios hundred percent
of a good but like that just seems to
that has to be there she said this is
her statement you can see the level I
had been bronzed on two sorry and I'm
gonna mince these important words you
can see the level I had been bronzed to
unset that day she wrote please
understand that my control of a shoot is
one non-existent in terms of creative
direction I believe that you and
completely when I leave the set and
anything gentle photo and post is out of
my control fully Hadid went on to
explain that although heavy bronzing and
Photoshop are part of Klein's style the
shoots creative direction was not
executed correctly and that the concerns
that have been brought up her ballad
okay honestly I agree with all of that
no see she has no say much she looks
like and the Photoshop actually I don't
know if that's true like she's like
please I'm sure she's like I don't like
that picture like they would delete it
but that's not my point I had two points
to make here I can't believe like we
live in a world where people like still
don't understand that where the line is
for blackface like LuAnn like come on
like I can't believe we're still talking
about back maize like I remember like
growing up like a celebrity did I
remember who was and it was like the
biggest deal in the world I'm like as it
should be but like can't we all learn
and like stop doing it like I just can't
but like I feel like I'm hearing about
please incident like once a month yeah
it's so offensive just stop doing it
yeah but I think that people it's kind
of like when you face doing something
and you don't realize how out of control
you're being a well so that wasn't
someone else to look at it to me like
you are very warped and that's not you
so that's the next point it's like how
do we know the line between like being
really tan and being offensive I think
it's just because I've gotten spray tans
before where I've straight up looks like
that
yeah not by choice but it happens I
don't act so where do we draw the line
Stephen Klein I think Stephen kind of
struggling with that as well
yeah draw the line but this kind of
gives me the Ives have like she's saying
she has no control over this and I
really don't think that she does but
then why was everyone like so hard on
kendall Jenner for the Pepsi commercial
she has no control over that
totally so are there they have
controller they don't which one is it I
don't think that they have control I
don't think models have control but I
think supermodels like Kendall and Gigi
like if they say they don't like it like
she doesn't get to approve the photo
like no but it's not about photo
approval maybe if she didn't like a
certain photo it's about the creative
direction of the entire shoot like after
one director post-production creative
director guy also is like in blackface
well we don't know who he is yes no we
do he's like he's also he's like a
famous athlete or something and like he
in real life is also extremely tail oh
my goodness it's like this is just such
a poor judgment on so many levels Jeff
and red eye and the thing is is like for
a Vogue magazine cover it's like make it
to print I think maybe 2,000 people have
to leave it all seem a September issue
yeah I've seen The Devil Wears Prada
like everyone and their mothers needs to
take a look at it and like not one
person was like you guys like
yeah nobody thought to say that maybe
they should hire us also like Vogue this
supposed to be the pinnacle of like
fashion editorial school and I feel like
they missed the mark and they are they
are [ __ ] up way too much for Vogue no
I mean between Photoshop like what they
did to Ashley Graham on that cover with
all the girls like Gigi's arm this like
bogan eats the whole company needs to do
a company-wide like sensitivity and
Photoshop training class not like you
know what like just use facetune if it's
like so hard they also need a workshop
on how to be in tune with what's
necessary because like what's shocking
to me is that Kim Kardashian has only
been on the cover of Vogue once and it
was the ugliest photo of all time and
literally all the stuff like it's
unbelievable what kind of power came
here - Tina's like when she wears
something that she's more like a legging
biker shorts like now everyone's wearing
them and they're gonna be in vogue like
she literally sets the standard like for
what school and she's only been on it
once with Kanye like she needs to be on
it by herself she was wearing the
ugliest wedding dress and had makeup
running down her face like she looked
horrible I didn't care what she was
wearing her makeup and her face was so
bad and like if I were her that cover
would give me a pit like you would think
it should be hanging in her house but
it's definitely not but it's just
unbelievable to me she's never been on
it again and that's how like Vogue is
like they're always one step behind
I agree like even the lesser magazines
that aren't as like cool like like L or
Harper's Bazaar they're like a little
below bug like they're very into W
always has came on the cover like they
are in tune with what's necessary like
wait than I do good even more than Kim
Kylie has never been on the cover of
Vogue that is a grave mistake and that's
why rumors say that Anna Wintour's is
around the summer well homie it needs to
be out like she just missed the mark on
so many things
yeah but especially the Kardashian
hunters and like ever since the first
year she invited them to the Met Gala
it's like they're the whole party like
you read write you believe me there's
not gonna they're not gonna enough for
Vogue but they're good enough for the
mecca of your party cool right like you
know one was talking about the metal
before Kim showed up in that mrs.
Doubtfire couch no people were talking
about it but I think no one was having
fun at the Met Gala until a Kardashian
syrup which is crazy because they barely
drink no totally I'm just telling you
like Anna Wintour not in tune with
what's necessary yet another example of
someone in power not being too
Oh Katya Kim has been on vogue Spain
just oh well I'm checking my Vogue
American because Kim is an American icon
and a princess and she should also be on
Vogue Armenia if that's the thing she
should be on every vogue anyway every
but I do hope the rumors are true that
Anna Wintour stepping down I think she
doesn't find job but I'm ready for
something new but something they did now
on the head did you see Rihanna's makeup
yes oh my god an alien on the head that
was Rihanna being Rihanna and being a
judoka finally doing something they do
those makeup mirror things all the time
it's like so boring cuz like models wear
no makeup Rihanna wears makeup like
YouTube makeup I was lip thing I bought
it I want to get everything that she's
that orange and purple palette is she a
purple looks amazing and her eyes I need
that and I need that brush she was using
for her highlighter okay I never
realized how big her forehead is it's
really big yeah but she contoured it so
well no she's great and she's like
someone was like how'd you learn how to
contour she's like when I got fat like I
needed to learn how to like relatable oh
yeah that video was so good and all the
fancy products looked so good I some of
them but I need to get more her just
Yeller also I need to get a baby blender
because what she was doing with her
concealer was everything I'm just like
I'm always surprised like for all those
vogue videos literally like SATA sampaio
like all those girls in Liberty now I
need blush and mascara and like I'm
wearing so much makeup like [ __ ] you
don't know what a lot of makeup is until
you see me before the test okay so
Rihanna like putting on real like baking
using concealer foundation like these
girls don't even wear foundation what I
do you know what I think it says a lot
that I've actually ever seen one of
those videos before Instagram all the
time and they're like I just like to see
their like their bathrooms like I just
find it interesting but Rihanna like
that video is just like I get why people
stand Rihanna and now I officially stand
Rihanna I stand Rihanna
I always but it's just everyone smile
I'm like she's [ __ ] epic no she's
epic and the interview revealed so much
about what happened with Drake did you
see that oh no I didn't so basically the
question was like are you guys still
friends cuz what had happened was that
she won that award at VMAs and he was
the one to introduce a try to kiss her
yeah and basically she what she said was
like I really didn't like that like
public display of affection I'm like
really shy and like hidden like making
that speech about how like amazing and I
am like
made me really uncomfortable and like
took away from my moment cuz then it was
about like Rihanna and Drake not about
like my career accomplishments she was
like I was really upset and we're not
friends anymore but like we're not
enemies we just don't talk
that's crazy have something like that
because I feel like all those award
shows are planned out too yeah so I
don't think something like that happens
by accident but apparently it does but
what's so great about this whole thing
is like everyone in the world wants to
date Drake like name me one person like
literally my friend at least he has mom
- yeah I'm semanas like I think my
daughter is great for you like once a
week and like when they were together it
was perfect but like she's so elevated
like even she doesn't want Drake no
imagine being that beautiful and
confident that you don't want or need
Drake I can't imagine no cuz I thought
but it must be nice but it's like it
goes it's again like confidence is why
everything you make it yep because even
when Rihanna she was saying like she has
ups and downs with her weight like it's
the same person she doesn't act any
differently but most people when you
have ups and downs with your weight like
it we're flexing your personality in the
way they carry yourself but it can be
like a depressing thing like gaining
weight trust me and it's like you don't
want to go out yeah and you don't have
any clothes to wear but your clothes
still fit just put them on and leave and
be confident I need to just get into
some venti products I don't have any
let's go to sport after that okay speak
I want that body shimmer and she was
like I used to go to Barbados and just
take oil and eyeshadow it was confusing
cuz was she saying it that she did that
as a kid or as like a famous person was
she on vacation I was thinking the same
thing I think it was as a kid okay well
I mean I want that anyways I see that
was like the only thing he likes like
literally butter and I want to eat it no
I want to spread her on a piece of warm
toast
she's like nice and and like soft I know
she is like milk addiction like you she
does yeah I'm gonna either and a piece
of warm toast okay
speaking of weight great segue I love
talking about weight I love like we're
experts on weight totally like for so
many reasons I'm definitely the expert
on how to gain it no but I'm not going
we're experts on it just about again how
to lose how to live with weight Rob
Kardashian hints at extreme weight loss
after Kanye West's liposuction comments
and says he's put in the work okay
exactly is he hinting he did an
Instagram caption saying I don't look
like this anymore smiley face hashtag
the transformation is coming
check stay tuned hashtag no surgery
hashtag couldn't work oh my gosh I'm so
excited I love skinny Rob I truly truly
only want good things for him even
though he attempted to take down his
whole family with the solute that it's
like China and how to spite baby with
her but I can look past that because I
love Rob like Khloe's helping him like I
just skinny Rob is like what we need
I agree but um I can't look past it yet
he has to pay his dues he hasn't
apologized to what he put us through let
alone his family his family will do
anything for him and like they don't
even require to have to take him back
but I do like you put this country
through such turmoil no I can't believe
like I wonder if Kylie's gotten an
apology for all of it Kylie did nothing
wrong just by dating someone and in turn
it tore her family apart just because
she was in love with T Tyga i I'm not
I'm not over it yet and yes him losing
weight is a start yes but it's not
everything because for so long all they
wanted him to do was lose weight and
leave the house and it's like instead of
doing that not only did he not do that
he went in the opposite maded with not
Chyna yeah and how despite baby sue me
you still have to make up for that and
come back to society yeah but this is
definitely a good first step I just
don't know if it's everything I think
he's like he's in bad shape in terms of
his mental health I feel like for so
long and maybe still now he thinks that
like losing weight would would care
everything right if he never swing for
what's gonna happen you have been really
an embrace gained weight and just like
had his fat boy swag right so I'm afraid
of what's gonna happen like he gets back
in shape and he thinks his whole life is
gonna turn around and like nothing
really changes because like it's not
losing weight can only do so much like
it's a it's an emotional mental thing
person in the body right so I'm afraid
we might see it another time where it's
fire all but like a skinny one okay
we'll stay tuned for that and I just he
needs to start filming again because I
don't give a damn what you're doing if
you're not showing me agreed this x-ray
is really [ __ ] crazy gez has been
busted for assault and cocaine
possession okay it's actually like not
that crazy if you saw the pictures of
him and Halsey on the boat on the boat
like doing coke not giving a [ __ ] that
picture never apologize for it never
tried to change their ways never tried
to say that they were doing anything
else wild wild like doesn't give a [ __ ]
so Jeezy was our
in Sweden after allegedly attacking
security guards and getting caught with
cocaine sources familiar with the
situation tell us the rapper was
partying in a club after his show
Wednesday in Stockholm and was acting
belligerent we're told several security
guards approached him asking him to calm
down but she easy started to throw
punches striking one guard in the face
several times isn't he like a skinny
he's like orange openings we're told he
was detained by police he was allegedly
discovered who allegedly discovered
cocaine in the rapper's pocket our
sources say he was taken into custody on
suspicion of assault possession of
narcotics and use of narcotics we're
told he's still in custody there's been
an update that leave obtained video gez
getting loaded into a police car and
then in another clip Halsey can be heard
yelling about getting hit in the face
we're told she may have been struck by a
security guard during the scuffle they
control just like even if I didn't know
anything about them just looking at them
like they're out of control and I'm
really shocked that like our culture is
so sensitive I am shocked that Halsey
doesn't get more [ __ ] for being like the
number one cultural appropriator like
what she does I think is out of control
with what just like well the two of them
together yes but like her specifically
like her outfits her the way she speaks
her hair her makeup like he's so what
like it's just not her she's a fraud and
she look I think sometimes people really
take it too far when it comes to
cultural appropriation like everyone
yelling at that girl for wearing like a
Geisha prom dress like she was 17 like
leave her alone I think sometimes but
like this specifically like everyone is
so quick to attack nobody says anything
about Jose like she is a fraud I agree
with that
and her Jeezy together are out of
control I also just hope that maybe like
this will make them like take stock of
their lives and be like it's not going
to maybe be she makes any changes so you
know I'm always in the blinds oh that's
why they don't say anything thank you
sorry I take it back
that's why um okay
losing the blinds oh but the blinds say
about her like her coke problem is out
of control but everyone knows that and
now a lot of people are also saying it's
also a cover-up
oh sorry know that she has endometriosis
and she's become like a spokesperson for
the illness but it's actually just a
cover up like she's ill because just
many drugs make sense
to be to be determined I hope that they
get the help that they need
um and that they can set a good example
for all the youngsters who listen to
their music I met a girl once who likes
stand halsy like and oh I know her yeah
yeah from him but well that was like pre
yeah Fame Halsey but Halsey like came up
with like this really strong fan base
and she's still like has these like
hardcore like emo fans but I figured I
was well on my way like but she doesn't
take into account their age and the
influence over them she doesn't take any
of that into account and like where are
they like I've seen videos of her on
tumblr like greeting her fans and she's
like there goes like do you remember me
she's like him in the park four years
ago what she knows it's like how can you
know that if you're on drugs I don't
know maybe she's superhuman okay
accidentally only pulled four stories so
I'm improvising the fourth story right
now which is that Mason Ramsey went on a
radio show you guys dog is freaky I
talked about how he has a girlfriend who
lives in a different state her name is
Madison and she's a redhead and quote
redheads are lucky shucks
so when he said that honestly it's not
like he's talking about a lame patch no
cuz 70 was not line Oh Madison oh I also
like Madalene pets doesn't protect me
son Ramsay at all calm down I know one
redhead who does do you think Madison
the redhead protects me some Ramsay like
he says he hasn't seen her since
February I wonder if it's like a redhead
thing that we be able to need to protect
Mason at all costs we should ask Jessica
Chastain if she feels the same we'll do
some field research we need to get
Mason's girlfriend on the show
and like do you think I don't think she
wants like that she doesn't want this
life you know she's kinda gal but if
he's gonna be famous for something he's
gonna be famous for loving her so she
better get used to the thing he's so
buddy cue him on that radio Shelley
could barely reach him I think he's also
like a little old man like way that he
talks he's just like such an old soul
like he's not a kid well him in the song
saying people ask him how's your girl
has your family like that line is so
[ __ ] funny like implying that Mason
Ramsey has kids like he's a kid or
supposed to think it means like a
grandparent or it's like how's yourself
shut also it's crazy that this song
famous has only been in my life for a
week because it's
for me if I'm gonna be famous for
something I wanna be famous for loving
you I'm gonna be known
oh we have some redheads in the common
so we're saying I'm around and I can
confirm the theory that you are
protecting me since I don't looks good
to no tact Mason Ramsey 2018
what other while we're on the topic are
there any other kind of redhead
conspiracy theories you would like to
debunk um we're not debunk but I could
bring up that apparently redheads have a
lower tolerance for pain so while you
think that you're actually in the most
pain like of anyone ever I actually have
a lower threshold a night you think
redhead yeah that would be so maybe you
got my pain that I feel like I know I
can't even take hot baths like I have a
lowest threshold that's right like I
really want to get kybella but like once
I mentioned it on the show yesterday a
lot of people DM to me they're like it's
so painful oh my goodness well once I
mentioned that I need Botox and cool spa
everyone was like it's the best decision
I ever made my life I would do it a
hundred more times I would do it every
week if I had to really yeah do it you
really should do what I was gonna do it
you've been staying over here's the
problem and this is why I realize like
your kybella thing is like this is why
you're and I'm a ninja on like yeah
because most people like me say I'm not
gonna do cool spot until I lose 10
pounds like I want to lose some hands
and then I'll do it the you are saying I
love how I am the way I am so I need
well I really am trying to like start a
healthier lifestyle so let me give it
like a month before I do cool spot but
Botox should happen tomorrow cuz it's
that but you can't skinny people need
cool spot it's not about that it's just
about jiggle no but like I want to lose
more fat before I get rid of my face
fair you know I'll allow it so stay
tuned for that and also we should find
someone who can give us Botox live on
the show I was gonna say would you ever
do like live stream Botox
only if I'm getting it for free because
yeah like but so well I was a lot of
people were DME made high bail and they
were recommending doctors and like they
were sending me doctors who have like
verified instagrams like I don't know
like I don't really want it instagram
instagram doctor like kendall sent me
like her real dermatologist like I would
do that like I don't know I feel like
you don't skimp like I would spend money
like free Botox just doesn't sound like
safe you know unless it's like dr.
ourian I mean of course also
redheads in anesthesia is the thing like
sometimes like if you're a redhead and
you got you have to get more anesthesia
because the regular amount like you
could wake up okay so I watched nip/tuck
stop and firstly a redhead it's the best
show of all time yes you just remind me
of something so there was an episode
that really stuck with me more basically
this girl there was like a serial killer
around the loose in Miami who was like
cutting girls mouths from their mouth to
their ear and these doctors were
repairing all the girls and the girl was
getting her face sewn up and you could
see her crying the doctors didn't notice
so then when she woke up she said she
felt and heard everything she was
paralyzed I'm like totally freaking
people out right now she was paralyzed
she was repeating backwards they were
saying during the surgery like and then
they believed her and it's like his
urban legend Ben's um uncle is an
anesthesiologist and I asked him I'm
like is this possible he's like it's an
urban legend like I've never seen it but
it's not impossible where basically you
get paralyzed by the anesthesia but
you're not unconscious so like you see
things you hear things you feel things
but you can't minute you're paralyzed
how do you feel the things
sorry paralyzed in the sense that you
can't move oh well that sucks
yeah and so like I'm so afraid to get
surgery because of this one episode of
nip/tuck okay mom god I haven't seen it
and also I'm a redhead so it's just
right and the girl was a redhead sorry
do that my spring like my she was her
I've had this happen or like it was just
well there's no casting choice I'm no
doctor but I think it was because she
was a redhead it only makes sense okay
well anyways Mason Ramsey says that
we're lucky so that means more to me
than anything but Mason Ramsey also said
how's your girl how's her family so
amazing MZ said and some of them with
you this makes no sense as long as I'm
with you I don't mind the picture it's
like that's a word that they changed
from fryer Victorians like regional song
yeah like it was definitely cuz I'm
going with you like I don't mind like
taking body shots off of bravery random
coming up and taking pictures like he
doesn't mind it cuz he's a girl at home
I don't know I'm just this is purely
conjecture we must get him actually
shouldn't look the lyrics let's do an
in-depth analysis of Mason Ramsey famous
lyrics how does it start
it's yeah it's pretty cool to be on TV
so while the folks back home could see
me so that's definitely an obvious line
you know he's made it Adam living it out
all the things I used to dream about so
hang on the Opera he literally that
strong should have been about the whole
time like making his dreams not about a
girl like weird no it's not weird it's
because if it was just the song that you
expected like it wouldn't have change it
yeah it's pretty great singing on stage
proud cuz there ain't an empty seat in
the place oh I can't I doubt that but
but girl ever since I met you I got a
whole new perspective if I'm gonna be
famous for something I wanna be famous
for loving you if I'm gonna be known
around the world
I wanna because of you girl nothin wrong
with the center of attention long as I'm
with you I don't mind the pictures okay
if I'm gonna be famous for something I'm
gonna be famous for loving and you need
a month to pass we're like heat goes
back into oblivion and he can come on
our show right wait yeah I hope yeah I
hope the first question people is having
a girl and how's your family
I could go on and on and on talking
about you for days you can bet when I
hear congratulations wanted to because
we made it another five years sleeping
together for five years since he was
four whatever it's so funny uh I [ __ ]
love him and I agree with that but I
don't think I mean I also hope that it
doesn't slow down for him so and that he
has longevity
char's to Mason Ramsey and his long
prosperous career and relationship long
prosperous career relationship and
education okay at anything else and that
please come on to show me soon we will
protect you at all costs no matter the
cost no matter the cost like we're not
making
right now but like we would spend it all
to protect you I would I would crowd
fund security detail for Mason Ramsey
that's his grandma's totally a security
guard um Chuck also he definitely is
performing at CMA fest that's another
reason why we have to have to purchase
what I was trying to say in the
beginning I'm speaking of Nashville we
need to book our trip to CMEs and
organize our live show maybe okay if
anyone has any suggestions for like good
theaters I can hold like a couple
hundred people tau couples out just a
couple hundred now because you the
Bridgestone Arena yeah I heard um I
heard like it's not that Ike yes no for
us yeah okay no seriously suggestions
for like small theaters I know where you
need to perform where the Bluebird
totally anybody has connections at the
Bluebird I would die I would bring a
guitar in like fully do a musical
episode oh my god that would be epic
I would like learn more music yeah so
that we could have a musical I said I
would accompany you and like I'm the
plan try really hard to get marinara's
if we did it like I feel like she would
come she loves the toast yeah I feel
like she would come to also Raylan would
come it would work a star set Carly
parse is anyone the bridge president
dick rusty dick Kaylee dick is anyone in
New York one in the front out to tonsure
Morgan Evans Kevin Morgan Evans Keller
Enoch it's crazy Morgan Evans came on
the show Lauren Alaina I think I would
be the most excited Brewer Elena me too
and rusty dick I just love him I love
them all honestly equally I know
betrayal in yeah and also we were
talking about patreon like some of our
favorite guests and I forgot to mention
that I think Raylan was like my all-time
favorite guys Muslim because she has
become like a lifelong friend and she's
like she's one of us she's like a little
teeny bopper but it's so crazy because
we couldn't have grown up like more
differently in like several parts of the
country and we just have so much in
common and that's so incredible about
humanity
okay there's an final story dramatic
Audrina Patridge and Ryan Cabrera are
getting pretty serious as she attends
his concert this is like so crazy no
what year is it I don't know the hills
star continues to spend more and more
time with her ex-boyfriend
most recently supporting the
singer-songwriter at his concert in Los
Angeles a source tells a news that our
Gina had a blast at the show and has
been very supportive of Ryan and his
music and has always been a band well
that makes three of us
the fact that he's a musician is one of
her favorite qualities okay well you
know this is all good fun but lest we
not forget who rang cabarrus true love
is and that's me because I got to
interview him and like we totally
connected what did you interview him for
I don't know interviewed him like a
while back when I was like a blogger but
like oh free year Bagh yeah and what are
you asking so I went to the show it was
like The Veronicas know the same
publicist but not that job but I went
and and I really felt like it was like
the Rolling Stones like I was a groupie
and like I was like to show my dad's and
did you know what was your like what was
the biggest question you had on their
mind forever I can go back and find it I
wanted to only ask about the hills but
like people hate when you like ask him
about the thing that made them famous
cuz people are annoying when I feel like
I was like who inspires you what did he
say he said I inspired him that makes
sense also the two of them went to stage
stage host last week together which
makes me like them more as a couple it
did no Gina patch to just have a baby
with someone else yeah with BMX rider
quarry Bowen but they're not really like
troubled waters I feel like okay but yes
I know that she had a baby because I
know that she had her Instagram reveal
pregnancy test sponsored by the
pregnancy test company blue first Cross
Blue Shield and it's remember but like
she posted her like thing goals honest
totally good for you make that baby
money you got a bike crash he works hard
yeah you ever seen in the back of a taxi
uh you ever see her after SNL first look
yeah that's the same big yeah like where
that girl Sarah is to do it it's like
the most annoying job but like but it
also isn't it's kind of like the ideal
job because it's like hosting which we
love yeah and you just get to like
travel and like no one really watches it
so like you know um to do a good job
right except I did watch an episode
after SNL and it was like crazy how they
realize that no one watches it cuz they
were like so many fuck-ups that like
they should have just ripped it it's
like they didn't it was like they were
livestream like someone said the wrong
thing and someone corrected them but
like why not just take them out totally
I don't know that is so funny you know
like speaking of so much Strong's into
that show Chuck stup yes so much rum
okay so talk stupids like honestly if
you die if you are to your whole life
like basically this woman Kat Greenleaf
got the show called talk stoop it was
like started literally like on taxi TV
then like on digital and then I think it
made it to you USA
I basically sheet a talk show I'm like a
Brooklyn stoop her front porch yeah and
it was called tough soup but then it
eventually turned into a set okay but
like and I was actually friends with
this woman cat yeah so it was like her
show her idea her stoop and they took it
away from her and they gave it to Nessa
Nessa from girl code girl code TRL
whatever which is like honestly good for
her like that's a great job but like
poor cat she invented the show and I
remember I don't know where I met her
but she was talking about it cuz I was
like shook and she was saying like she
got on taxi TV she was like you couldn't
get arrested to be on taxi TV like no
one wanted to be a backseat EP and she
like invented taxi TV totally she
invented me being motion sick in the
back of a cab and she's a good
interviewer like she didn't already and
she's like hi bad turn she accidentally
hit her in the face
and it's so funny no she's great she's
so funny no honestly look it made me sad
sad people lose their shows she also
Jackie etcetera people lose their shows
it's really sad she also said that she
lost it because she was like going
through like depression or anxiety and
so she couldn't like do some of the
things that she was used to doing and
they took her show away because of that
unfair she filed the lawsuit says she
filed a lawsuit against NBC Universal
and honestly hope she was justice for
Kat Greenleaf being served up I was like
a little extra dresses for me
surrounding just in case and I will
lecture justice for me I got my period
like everyone should just feel bad for
me and the little extra dresses for me
um to shoot it because I need it and I
I'm going through the induction flow
which is when you start Atkins and your
body is like in shock and can't move
okay oh you don't want to know how I'm
doing on Atkins well here's a really fun
fact alcohol does not have carbs vodka
has literally zero carbs white wine has
like one or two depending on the flavor
champagne is like the most carbee but
you can literally be on Atkins and drink
every day and every night and still lose
maybe I should consider it which is why
it's a really good dye because most
diets you have to factor in alcoholic
calories but yeah you should also
probably like cut back on the drinking
if you want to lose weight even faster
but also you should live your life so I
still have a glass of wine or two when
those are my carbs for the day but so L
were your life
Oh what let's try that again
so live your life that's what the song
was
I was just doing the beats no live your
life hey okay but I got I got the rhythm
right so I want to talk about some TV
cuz I'm not like because we went away
like my whole life has been set back a
week so hopefully by next week I'll be
back on my whole life I know but I did
catch up on a limited amount of TV
including Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills
I watched half of the second part of the
reunite oh I watched the first part
while we were in Turks like while I
wasn't really high that's a strong
thought I didn't watch a second half I
don't think I missed much I have strong
thoughts too one being that it wasn't
until the reunion when I realized how
boring this season has been I don't mind
some of them seasons are boring but like
you get good things out of it so like I
don't care like Orange County last
season was boring and I got nothing out
of it so I was mad Beverly Hills it was
boring but I got good things out of it
like I love to read I love Lisa and I
got Lisa Rinna Erika Jayne friendship
like my hardest oh Lisa Rinna Erika
Jayne to recapture a friendship that I
didn't know that I needed I have three
points I want to make about Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills reunion
Camille Tomodachi he's out of control
she's a sponsored general day night and
overtime to make of that housewife title
she was trying so hard
anyone literally like winked at her the
wrong way she was a what's with the
attitude no but here's the thing the
reason why Camille has been in the good
graces of societies because she's been
like so overran and laid back and
relaxed in like cool that we were like
oh my gosh who was this a beautiful
amazing grace of a woman but now that
she's being athirst monster to get back
into the house side it's the exact
reason why she lost house I can win one
yeah so he's out of control and like she
with that ball gag like I don't agree
with anyone and honestly like it
obviously serves to eat right like she
gets a gag gift when she gave me a gift
I get it but like everyone was being so
mean to to read at that lunch FLC what
is about the gift yeah Lisa we doing the
cup signal ahead he likes everyone
laughing at her and it was just too much
yes the clips gag Cup so it was just too
much also when to reach it those things
to Camille she was like almost logout
yeah there has to be and um Camille this
was all premeditated sober daytime and
and it's just different treats credit
she did apology
immediately for calling her stupid
c-word yeah like you can't not know and
it's like who's women apologize and like
move past things and then like they go
to the reunion to pretend like they're
still like pertinent yeah that's
actually you have to be able to move on
and that's what garite was saying to
teddy so you keep on a recessed to take
these things that are dead and done I
really like I hate Tori I mean I hate
teddy and she said something that really
pissed me off she was like you're still
dismissive when you talk to me like
that's such a blanket statement I'm like
you can't disagree with that she's not
giving specific examples she's like I
just feel like you're dismissive first
of all that's a really mean thing to say
like if that is what Tory is doing but
be like that's just like you can't argue
with that you're not saying like you
were dismissive here you're saying your
tone overall is dismissive when it comes
I know it's not first of all and be like
that's just an unfair argument Ori isn't
dismissive towards anyone cuz she
literally doesn't dismiss anyone cuz all
she does is keep talking yeah second
thing I want to talk about is Erica Jane
it's just total an interest in being
alive during that reunion
I heard from a reliable source I think
it was someone on Twitter said it that
she had a horrible migraine and I get
bad migrants too and if you're under
studio lights and rang full hair makeup
and your hair is pulled back in a
ponytail and you have a migraine like
you can't even breathe like I if that's
the truth
I believe it and she when she's talking
like she literally or she has no emotion
she's not even moving her eyebrows it's
like her face hurts so bad she's like
yes she's not like yes you know II mean
yeah I don't know her behavior was
bothering me and it made me feel like
she's kind of over being a housewife the
migraine thing makes me feel a little
bit better but I don't know like I get
really terrible migraines and coupled
with my hangovers and if I had to show
up to work that day and like be a human
being like you speak when spoken to you
don't dismiss
I agree but I'm sorry like when I have a
migraine you don't even look at my way
like I'll [ __ ] you up
I know it's just unfortunate because
it's unfortunate because I needed to
hear from her yeah and I need it and
what she doesn't do that house I just do
that get somebody's trouble but it also
like keeps them relevant it's like she
never liked offers her opinion on
situations that have nothing to do with
her which is probably smart but like
sometimes someone needs someone to back
them up and if America did it it would
be dead and done like if Erica back
would surely against any like no but she
backed up to read against Lisa for the
magazine thing magazine thing Beverly
Hills lifestyle okay that little man
who's like I don't want that negativity
in my scene like I would love to punch
him
if you don't want negativity in your
magazine don't work with Lisa Vanderpump
no totally and like it was mean that
they cut her off oh and everyone on that
couch pretending like they wouldn't be
so pissed if they found out the day
before that they were gonna be on the
cover of a magazine and weren't allowed
to use her own glam literally every time
I've ever been at a photo shoot I cry
totally I cry all the time like and
Erica was the only one telling truth
like all these old [ __ ] they wouldn't
be so upset if they didn't have
Priscilla and Julius Caesar who does
their hair like they would be really mad
like and that was really pissing me off
making Jared seemed like she was hi Mina
no no like if you're a woman of a
certain lifestyle you are very
comfortable with certain hair and makeup
people and like when people do my hair
and makeup that I don't they start
crying when they dream it is the biggest
thing in your career thus far being a
magazine also not only did she not get
her hair and makeup people what they did
what those hair makeup people did do
acrimony was terrible if they had done a
good job in there he was upset I would
have like had less sympathy Turner also
he may look like a westerly see her face
looks terrible in front of makeup artist
was me know you would do the same thing
of course if some of me you look like a
wet crazy dog she looked at you might be
able to help yourself
and I just like I just hate listener
problem agree I just hate her and
everyone's saying Erica is gonna quit
first of all I haven't got authority
that she's not from an extremely
reliable source and she's the only one
who is can really help facilitate the
takedown of Lisa Vanderpump so
everything's it's over it's over we're
in a tried she's not trying again
no Rinna this her daughter's mas work
because of it so Rinna that was crazy
mm-hmm I was bragging about thinking
that when Delilah Belle and Amelia were
saying that they learned how to give a
blow job from their moms but I was like
thinking like they probably out in so
much trouble afterwards like for saying
that cuz that made these we're gonna
look really bad it did but do you think
Lisa Rinna's like a strict mom like that
yeah she was then they would be scared
of her and they wouldn't have said it
may be me but I think they like really
want like to use the show as I could
jump golf platform so they wanted to be
like funny and out there I was just
thinking like they totally got to
talking to after and I was like laughing
that's really funny I had one more thing
to say about Kyle's burglarize Asian so
seven people are talking about it on the
show and like at the time I like realize
how severe it was like and how sad it is
and I didn't realize that she was in a
new house which she's definitely moving
at it like this wouldn't have happened
if
in her old house no it's by the way I
have you know I've heard anything no no
first of all what's really sad is like
not even like the Birkins it's like the
stuff her mom gave her like before her
mom died everything but what's even
crazier
teni Teddy's husband was doing the
security like she had daddy better in
law I can't I can't
and like yes the security wasn't up and
running yet but like it should have been
and also when Teddy was like but my
husband's company sent the tech hello
[ __ ] are you kidding you're always
reading comments and I'm probably is
responding to you and you were still
talking I mean you were mid-sentence you
guys thank and someone wrote read
Rihanna's vogue interview she goes on
and on about how she loves this event
her pomp I read that very upsetting no
it's just because like Rihanna can like
Lisa manor of him because like she don't
have to worry about the little people
but I worry about the little people and
Lisa hadn't promised crushing them under
her big feet
I just [ __ ] except Lisa van from what
she did the tits on her dress like that
was funny no no I thought it was fun no
I really really hate her
what I was saying was when Teddy was
like well my husband's company sent the
text do not be proud
well hours later yeah it's just really
sad like I feel like Kyle's so like
emotional my family got her old house
back I don't know but it was a safe
place nothing bad happened there nobody
loved her new house if I were her every
time I walk into the house would give me
a pit yeah but like yeah yeah she said
they were considering moving I spoke to
a lot of people who have been
burglarized is that a thing and I like
the Bruce burger yes the bling ring yeah
they should go talk to her Lexus Nayar
see if she knows oh and she walks like a
ten minute clip of Alexis Neiers talking
to Nancy Jo and the phone Nancy Jo this
is Alexis Neiers if you okay literally
that is the most epic scene in reality
so emic Tess is just over her like over
Alexis being so supportive you know but
like mom was out of control that show
was everything and like what happens
when II was in tune with what's
necessary what was the deal between Tess
and Alexis like there were in sisters
but they were like lovers lovers
yeah but Lex just like went to jail and
I was like so normal I wish and kids and
like she's like very spiritual what is
where is Tess
where's has more
where's kale is the mom like the mom was
out of control she was a Kris Jenner
wannabe in the making know that show was
like it was on Netflix for a while do
you think it still is it's definitely on
him Amazon Prime so it's so good I just
like I missed the days when he was like
cool that's so crazy that like she got a
reality show and she was like robbing
home the day they started filming that's
so crazy they were like so pretty they
were everything we were obsessed with
them no I love them I need to go watch
it now
did you ever see The Bling Ring in the
movie yeah where's Emma Watson was
actually really good in that she's too
like proper proper for the role like I
wish it was someone who was like more
true to what a next Alexis Neiers like
really was yeah like a basket case we
need to get Alexis Neiers on the show I
don't think she's like about that life
anymore
that's crazy she's private on Instagram
that's crazy that like you can be the
biggest thirst monster like of all time
the thirst monster general of generals
and no the thirst master lieutenant no I
think general is all right
the thirst monster commander chief okay
there's monster crap mandarin chief and
now you're just like a regular you're
the sorry people she thinks she's the
queen and were the sorry people I love
that clip anything else I know we will
catch up on all other television yeah
I'm behind on riverdale for a Honi
better pump Vanderpump southern charm
etc we will get we will get to next week
we promise thank you guys wait till
let's do a toast
oh we didn't toast to me sometimes but
no like we're protecting him five - you
know honestly I hope Basin Ramsay has
the most amazing weekend
filled with like love light and I hope
in Madison I hope he gets a chance to
see his girlfriend this weekend today
really remember like what's important in
life Cheers cheers to that
cheers to you guys thank you guys so
much for watching today on cuatro de
Mayo we are back on Monday obviously you
guys know the morning toast is live
Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time every day on
Facebook YouTube and then uploaded later
on the podcast app so make sure you like
us on Facebook of the morning toast make
sure you follow us on youtube the
morning toast and then leave a
subscription and a five star review on
our morning twist podcast page which is
available in the podcast app if you have
an iphone and if you don't worry about
long SoundCloud as
well my tickets to Cowan's finally went
back on sale so if you want to get GA
and I've released a few more GA tickets
so like your they're only $25 you have
no excuse not to come and yeah I'm on my
quest to 100k
so whenever you guys want to help me get
there it's whenever you guys just want
to do it and also I posted a youtube
video yesterday of a question I get all
the time and I worked so hard on it so
please go watch it move it to 20 of my
favorite Kylie lip kit colors and why
it's ten colors three pink three nude
for Reta gave a bonus read Mary Jo okay
let's go enjoy our weekend because I'm
so [ __ ] high okay so like it's about
to be the weekend what do you like for
yourself this weekend I hope that I
don't get hung over because we have lots
of birthday festivities and I hope I
just get to sleep and spend really good
quality time with you what does quality
time look like watching friends early
going in the park well for me it's
watching friends for him it's going the
park maybe do a little bit of both we
fell asleep together last night and it
was magical Ben is so annoying he always
puts the o' in the crate I'm like leave
him in the bed but we fell asleep he was
so tired and like oh my god it was
amazing that's amazing
I hope for this weekend that I don't get
hung over because that would just be
deadly and that I'm able to stick to my
diet mhm and that I do some home
furnishing and repairs that must get
done because I'm living in squalor if
you don't do it I will ever do it ever
you should get a ceiling fan if I liked
anything
why didn't do anything for me in Turks
and Caicos our era was like barely
working but the ceiling fan was
circulating the cold air it's amazing if
you're like if you are you a warm
sleeper is that no we're good on a/c
okay no but it's not even a see it's
just like that extra puff I'm getting a
ceiling fan in my next house okay well I
need to like go to Home Depot and build
shelves so pray for me bye guys have a
good become we'll see you on Monday
[Music]